my name is Micah Sal I'm 20 years old
and I'm from Damascus Syria
I'm really hoping to become a commercial
pilot one day and you know perhaps be
the first-ever female Syrian refugee
pilot I was 11 when the war started and
it just moved closer and closer until it
happened in Damascus we're always
prepared that we're gonna lose something
at some point because that's what war
does that's what everyone has faced and
experienced during the war is them
losing something whether like a relative
loved one their house their businesses
and different stuff so it was always
tough whenever like like my parents
would leave the house it would they
would say goodbye as if we might never
see them again so we were like we were
not living my mom my tiing or brothers
and I got from Damascus to Lebanon to
access the airport and then from the
airport we went to Turkey and then from
Turkey to Birmingham I've always
believed that education is what going to
define my future and education is how I
can represent myself my country my
family where I'm from I knew the kind of
stereotypes that people have about
refugees of being uneducated unskilled I
just feel like when people look at me I
don't want them to define me with these
kind of stereotypes and labels you
should not expect that first person is
uneducated unskilled just because they
came from a refugee background you don't
expect them to be broken and sad and
like you know to pass like they can be
you do offer your best support and like
try to be the kindest you can but also
expect that you're treating just a
normal human being with normal ambitions
and hopes and dreams